[Musique]
leur offrir le monde avant qu'il ne
perde la vue trois des quatre enfants de
la famille Pelletier sont atteints d'une
rétinite pigmentaire qui va
graduellement réduire leur vision
périphérique ils verront le monde dans
un tunnel la plus belle chose que j'ai
vu
c'était au capados quand on faisait la
montgolfière c'est vraiment beau ou
lever du soleil la Namibie pourquoi à
cause des camping puis du paysage et des
animaux
ils ont entre 5 et 12 ans et reviennent
tout juste un voyage de 384 jours dans
13 pays pour l'instant leur champ visuel
de jour est excellent donc on en a
profité pour aller voir non seulement
des beaux paysages mais aussi des
paysages très vastes où ils peuvent
vraiment apprécier
la grandeur des espaces nous c'était de
remplir la mémoire visuelle c'est le but
du voyage pour moi la société compulsif
de prendre des photos pendant le voyage
je voulais capturer chaque seconde parce
que c'est ce qu'ils vont être capable de
voir les photos pendant longtemps
les souvenirs rattachés aux photos ils
vont les consulter longtemps le
diagnostic final est tombé en 2018 après
des mois d'investigation médicale et
génétique
tu as vu c'est de faire au moins 10
échanges c'est un non seulement Mia mais
pour des quatre qui était atteints de
cette maladie-là qui est dégénérative
Satan ce qui soit complètement aveugle à
la mi-vie pour pouvoir le vivre puis
faire quelque chose avec
pandémie oblige le départ a été retardé
de deux ans et l'itinéraire initialement
modifié même si la pandémie est encore
longue on va aller où c'est ouvert puis
on verra pour le reste la fréquencetrale
est ouverte on a commencé par la Namibie
de l'Afrique à l'Asie il y a eu des
destinations coup de foudre et des
rencontres marquantes quotidien comme un
budget à la maison tu donnes un budget
puis tester le respecter pour respecter
leur budget de 120 000 dollars ils ont
fait de longs trajets en bus bondé ou en
train avec leurs trois valises pour 6
tout en faisant du français et des maths
en même temps ce qu'on a réalisé c'est
que les plus belles expériences
n'étaient pas nécessairement les plus
dispendieuses
[Musique]
puis j'ai réalisé que avec la rétine
c'est quelque chose qui va avoir besoin
parce que toute leur vie leur vision va
changer effectivement toujours être en
adaptation et vraiment besoin de se
réadapter tout le temps sincèrement on
est très très privilégié de pouvoir de
ne pas avoir des d'urgence de
recommencer à travailler
sur la ligne de l'équateur et des îles
Galapagos la famille repart en Amérique
du Sud cet été pour inclure un autre
continent à leurs souvenirs
[Musique]
bravo et puis avec nous docteur Cynthia
Chan vous êtes ophtalmologiste
rhinitologue à Sainte-Justine
Maisonneuve également merci d'être avec
nous
vous êtes leur c'est vous qui les suivit
n'est-ce pas
c'est exact donc je connais la famille
depuis l'année 2017 et en fait en
regardant le reportage je pense que
c'est extrêmement touchant et j'ai eu la
chance de connaître les enfants et des
voix grandir au fur et à mesure des
années alors de les avoir de retour au
Québec je viens de voir la semaine
dernière c'est très très touchant de
suivre le récit à distance et aussi en
personne maintenant bon dans le
reportage la mère dit à la mi-vie on
s’attend ce qu'il perde trois des quatre
là qu'il perdent la vue complètement
est-ce que c'est vraiment ça elle a mis
vie on ne peut rien faire il ne verront
plus du tout
alors quand vous entendez la rythmique
pigmentaire c'est la condition qu'on les
enfants dans ce cas-ci comme dans la
plupart des cas c'est causés par une
mutation génétique et dans le cas ici de
la famille depetis c'est le même gène
qui a été retrouvé chez trois des quatre
enfants l'évolution de la rétine vient
peu à peu progressivement et peut
commencer très tôt dans l'enfance donc
les parents souvent vont remarquer que
le comportement visuel et peut-être
différent des autres enfants soit à la
maison ou avec les amis dès l'âge
souvent un an deux ans ou trois ans et à
partir de là c'est une détérioration
graduelle de la vision qui peut en effet
aller jusqu'à la cécité non seulement
légale mais aussi complète mais ce
processus là est très lent et peut
arriver de façon très hétérogène c'est à
dire ça peut toucher quelqu'un à
vingtaine d'années tout comme ça peut
toucher quelqu'un plus tard à la
cinquantaine ou soixantaine donc
il y a de l'espoir pour que la descente
vers la noirceur en tout cas un peu noir
ça soit la moins abrupte possible
exact on espère que la descente soit le
plus le plus lent possible et en même
temps on essaye par de la recherche et
les travaux de trouver des moyens
d'ajustement la renverser au lieu juste
de l'avoir progressivement donc
actuellement on ne peut pas renverser on
ne peut pas remplacer on peut pas il y a
pas des vous travaillez par ailleurs
vous êtes une grande spécialiste sur des
yeux bioniques on ne peut pas en 2023
trouver une solution à ça
il y a des solutions qui commencent
alors comme j'expliquais la rétine
pigmentaire c'est un terme qui englobe
plusieurs conditions alors on parle de
plusieurs gènes qui peuvent tous
finalement causer la rythique
supplémentaire mais le traitement de une
forme ne veut pas nécessairement dire
que c'est un traitement universel pour
toutes les familles ou toutes les
personnes atteintes alors depuis le
temps qu'on avait créé la recherche en
deuil ionique justement que vous avez
mentionné il y a eu des innovations et
maintenant ce qui est de plus innovateur
c'est la thérapie génique dans lequel où
on en est fait on commence à remplacer
la mutation qui se trouve chez une
personne en espérant que en remplaçant
le gène qui est en faute qu'on va
pouvoir renverser cette perte visuelle
donc en ce moment il y a une forme de
plantaire qui est maintenant très table
mais ce n'est pas c'est malheureusement
pas la forme dont on les enfants de la
famille Pelletier est-ce qu'on peut
imaginer docteur chêne parce qu'on parle
beaucoup des progrès phénoménaux de
l'intelligence du ciel et tout ça on
voit des opérations hallucinant est-ce
qu'on peut imaginer qu'on pourrait
remplacer les yeux d'enfants qui ont
cette maladie là un jour
moi je dis toujours que je garde espoir
et que tout est possible c'est sûr que
on va un peu avec la vitesse de la
technologie alors c'est ce qui nous
limite un petit peu si la vitesse à
laquelle des solutions sont retrouvées
comme je vous dis par exemple en ce
moment il y a la forme qu'on appelle
l'amoureuse congénitale de Liebherr qui
est une forme très sévère de rythmique
alimentaire qui est maintenant traitable
et en fait justement lundi il y a deux
jours on a fait le premier traitement de
pour cette autre maladie là une forme
sévère dressimiquementaire ici à
l'univers de Montréal avec l'Hôpital
Maisonneuve-Rosemont donc mon espoir
c'est que ces progrès celui-ci qui avait
pris 24 ans pour aller d'une d'un rêve à
la réalité que avec la technologie qu'on
a maintenant ça va beaucoup raccourcir
le cheminement entre la découverte les
études jusqu'à le déploiement du
traitement pour toute forme de rythmique
pigmentaire autrefois si on avait dit
il y a 150 ans qu'on allait
qu'on allait changer les cœurs etc on
est ravi des gens on peut espérer des
grands progrès merci d'ailleurs ce dont
vous parlez on a un reportage de près
qu'on va diffuser cette semaine sur
cette percée importante docteur Chan
merci beaucoup je rappelle vous êtes
donc ophtalmologiste
à Sainte-Justine à Maisonneuve vous êtes
une grande spécialiste merci de nous
avoir parlé merci beaucoup au revoir